all righty so the President of the
United States is in supremely hot water
after he calls a bunch of countries
bleep holes and then suggests that
people shouldn't immigrate from there to
here we will explain what the
controversy is about from every possible
angle plus we've got the mailbag and the
media have decided that they don't
actually have to use bleeps anymore
they're just gonna say straight out
holes so we'll talk about all those
things I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
[Music]
it's another day in another controversy
which means that all of Twitter all of
the news cycle all of Facebook is now a
flaming bleep hole this is where we are
now yes it wasn't as though anyone could
have predicted that life would become a
turd tornado should fish should politics
make a turn in this direction
no one ever would have used that sort of
language say hmm a year ago two years
ago but you know we'll just leave that
out there okay before I go any further I
want to say the next Tuesday January
16th you should tune in at 5 p.m.
Eastern 2 p.m. Pacific to daily wire
comm or our Facebook page or our YouTube
page because we're doing our fifth
episode of the conversation which
features Andrew Clavin and Alecia Kraus
subscribe today and you become part of
the conversation you can ask drew live
questions and he will answer those for
everyone to hear again his conversation
is gonna stream live I'm Dylan we're
Facebook page if you want to ask
questions you have to go over to our
website at Daley we're calm click on the
conversation page you can watch the live
stream just type your questions into the
daily wear chat box and Alicia will
funnel those to Drew so you can only do
that if you subscribe again you can get
your questions answered by Andrew Clavin
Tuesday January 16th 5:00 p.m. Eastern 2
p.m. Pacific and join the conversation
so I'm very eager to break down
everything to do with president Trump's
alleged at remarks I say alleged because
it's not clear whether he actually said
them he's now denied saying them bunch
of people in the room say that he said
them we don't know what he said or how
he said it there's no context there's no
tape we'll get to all of that in a
second first I want to say thank you to
our sponsors over at texture so you love
information and you love in-depth
information going in-depth reporting
well that's where the magazine business
really does some great stuff you know
daily wire we have a lot of great
commentary and we have a lot of great
quick hit reporting but if you want
these sort of in-depth love forum
profiles where you learn to in-depth
information about topics that's what
magazine industry really does a
tremendous job texture gets you their
texture has leading titles like time the
Atlantic the New York or Vanity Fair and
wired and right now you can try a
texture for free it's better than print
because you get it all digitally you can
have over 200 of your favorite magazines
and their back issues anytime anywhere
you're sitting around your board you
pull out your your iPad and suddenly
you're looking at back issues of Sports
Illustrated it's fantastic check your
tell you can go to texture comm slash
bend right now texture comm slash Ben
and you get a free trial texture calm /
Ben and if you
and you love it then you get texture
comm for $9.99 a month and that's 30%
off they're listed price section more
than 30% off the de listed price you get
a discount when you use texture comm
slash men and you get your free trial
and then if you choose to continue then
texture comm slash Ben allows you to get
texture for just $9.99 a month which is
over 30% off their listed price texture
comm slash pen make sure that you're
getting the best and most in-depth
information that the magazine industry
has to offer again that's like less than
the cost very often of getting one or
two of these magazines subscribed mega
200 which is pretty awesome okay so
yesterday all hell breaks loose all hell
breaks loose because the President of
the United States has been bipartisan
meeting over deferred action for
childhood arrivals now Trump thinks he's
behind closed doors I need things this
is an off-the-record conversation as
Trump should know by now when you're in
a room with Democrats and Republicans
the chances of what you say remain on
background or secret are very very slim
to none Trump apparently forgot this
little problem and so he decided to
sound off about immigration so here's
what the Washington Post originally said
so they reported yesterday that Trump
had have been having a conversation
about protecting immigrants from Haiti
El Salvador and African countries right
and when he was talking about El
Salvador that was particularly of
interest because the Trump
administration had moved to basically
revoke the the temporary visas for
people who have been from in the United
States from El Salvador 200,000 of them
they've been there for seven for I think
15 years and in Trump provoked some of
their visas we don't know the context of
the comments it's unclear where Trump
made these comments but here is what he
said we don't know whether he's talking
about the visa diversity lottery program
or whether he was talking about targeted
deportation of illegal immigrants from
particular countries that doesn't make a
difference because here's what Trump
supposedly said he said quote why are we
having all these people from bleep whole
countries come here bleep is another
word for poop okay why are we having all
these people from bleep whole countries
come here and then the post continues
Trump then suggested that the United
States should instead bring more people
from countries such as Norway whose
Prime Minister he met with Wednesday the
president according to a White House
official also suggested he'd be open to
more immigrants from Asian countries
because he felt they helped the United
States economically
he then reportedly continued why do we
need more Haitians take them out so Jake
Tapper reports that what he meant by
that is who specifically
about revoking the the temporary visas
for Haitians who have been here after
the the earthquake about ten years ago
so those that's the entirety of the
comments right that apparently he's
talking about Haiti and African
countries and he said why are we having
all these people from bleep whole
countries come here and then he said why
do we need more Haitians take them out
so I'm gonna give you my basic take on
on all of this but in light of how
people have reacted to this so there
have been a bunch of reactions against
these comments obviously is this
something that the President of the
United States should be saying not even
close not even close okay this is not
something the presidents of the United
States should be dropping in private or
public it's kind of yucky and not just
is it yucky the implication could be
taken is racist now I'm gonna give you
two possible reads of his comments it's
very hard to read by the way the second
comments why do we need more Haitians
take them out as anything but bigoted
but those first comments why are we
having all these people from bleep whole
countries come here people aren't taking
this to mean that he means that everyone
from bleep whole country is a bleep hole
and that's why they shouldn't come here
I'm not sure that that is fully in
evidence so there's a few reasons why
people are angry today and what we'll go
through why people are angry and as we
go through you will see sort of why I
think that that this may be a little bit
overblown depending on how you interpret
his comments first of all let me explain
the vagary in the comments there are two
ways of interpreting this comment way
one is he's saying they're bleep whole
countries and the people from those
countries are bleep hole errs and
therefore they shouldn't come to the
United States this would be bigotry
right to suggest that patients cannot
come to the United States because
Haiti's a bad country is just sewing
okay it's just a silly idea it's not
just silly it's it's bigoted it's racist
it's counterproductive the huge number
of Haitian immigrants come to the United
States and get college degrees I believe
that the the statistic is something like
four new African immigrants four
countries Haiti's not in Africa but from
four African immigrants the number of
people who come to the United States and
get college degrees actually higher than
the American population at large
immigrant populations very often are
escaping bad countries that's the reason
they're coming here and so they know why
their countries are bad right look at
Cuban immigrants who are coming from
Cuba
Cuba's kind of a bleep hole country
according to many Cuban expatriates
that's why they're leaving that's why
they're coming here the same thing is
true of the Vietnamese boat people who
left and came here because they're
trying to escape the
production of their country so the idea
that you're coming from a country that's
a bleep hole and therefore you're a
bleep hole is obviously racist and silly
and bigoted a huge percentage of people
who came over from Nazi Germany ended up
being wonderful citizens of the United
States Germans and Jews alike the same
thing is true people who are trying to
escape Russian pogroms and polish
pogroms same thing is true of people who
come from China the vast majority of
immigrants to this country are wonderful
people who are trying to do hard work
and enrich the country by coming here
since the suggestion you can judge a
person from the country because they're
from the country is of course bigotry
and people who are reading from comments
this way have a little bit of support in
the idea that Trump has said in the past
for example that a Mexican judge could
not properly judge him because he was
Mexican so people are looking at Trump's
track record of linking ethnicity to
politics or to judgment or to capacity
and they're saying that this fits in
with those comments so that's a
plausible read here's another plausible
read okay and this is the one people are
ignoring the other plausible read is
that Trump is saying look we have a
diversity diversity visa lottery program
and the diversity visa lottery program
is designed to take in people by country
it doesn't evaluate them on an
individual level now let me backtrack
for a second my own position on
immigration is if there is no welfare if
there is no social safety net I am for
free and open immigration whoever wants
to come can come I don't have a problem
with anybody coming here so long as
they're not mooching off anyone I don't
care what country they're from I do care
about cultural impact I do care about
the viewpoints they suppose they're not
coming here to be violent if they
assimilate to American ideology I don't
care where you are from okay that said
the diversity visa lottery program is
the opposite of that the diversity visa
lottery program says that we are
specifically going to bring people in
from down trodden countries from
countries that don't send a lot of
immigrants through the legal immigration
process we're going to go to those
countries and bring in a large number of
immigrants from those specific countries
originally the diversity visa lottery
program was actually designed to get
more Irish immigrants into the country
in 1965 because there'd been a rapid
decrease in the number of Irish
immigrants entering the country and so
they wanted to use the diversity visa
lottery to increase the number of Irish
apparently in 65 that shifted in 1990
and the number one beneficiary of
diversity visa lottery program are
people from African countries so here's
what Trump could be saying he could be
saying
if we have to judge people only by
country and we're not gonna look at them
as individuals which is really how we
should do an immigration program we
should look at people and say is this a
good person or is this a bad person is
this someone we want in the country or
is this someone we don't want in the
country right that's the way we should
do immigration always but the diversity
visa lottery program says okay you're
from Ghana you get in you're from France
you don't write that that's that's
really how the lottery program works and
so Trump might be saying listen that
seems backward to me in the sense that
if you are just going to take as the
only descriptor the country of origin
you have to look at the country of
origin and country of origin does make a
difference it is easier put it put aside
race it's easier for example to
integrate someone from Great Britain
into American ideals than it is to
integrate somebody from say Russia in
American ideals now Russians are still
white people but the idea that you're
coming from a government where there's
no history of American ideology that
meant that makes no difference at all on
average it does make a difference and
I'll give you some statistics later that
show that it make a difference but the
point is this we shouldn't be responding
to the diversity visa lottery by doing
what Trump said which is bringing more
people from Norway we should be saying
no diversity visa lottery because every
individual should be elevated or dead or
degraded on their merits we should have
a merit based immigration immigration
system that's the way that we should do
this so those are the two plausible ways
of reading what Trump said now in a
second I'm going to explain to you all
the various ways that people have taken
his comments and the way that the left I
have to say they are so stupid because
they have a win here right if they want
to hit Trump is a racist it's not hard
to get from point A to point B but they
somehow completely miss point B and they
just go to point Z it's truly crazy I'm
gonna show you in just a second but
first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at Tommy John so right now
this moment I'm wearing the best
underwear that I have ever worn they are
just spectacular Tommy John's okay
innovative designs patented fabrics it
ensures that your underwear doesn't ride
up it's true it does not write up the
waistband does not roll down you will
never get a wedgie you don't have to
it's it's really comfortable it's
stretchable you never have to adjust its
it's like these underwear are truly
magnificent and they have some unique
design features that are quite
convenient and wonderful so check out
Tommy John's okay I've tried a bunch of
different underwear brands and this one
is the best okay Tommy John I can say
even if they were not an advertiser
saying this Tommy John's is the best
they've taken their comfort expertise
they've applied it to the rest of your
apparel as well so you can get
undershirts that stay tucked socks that
don't fall down
second skin tees that are really really
soft and a choice of smart fabrics for
every situation or outfit also if you
don't like it they have a best pair
you'll ever wear or it's free guaranteed
so you've got nothing to lose you order
it you don't like it and it's free so
Tommy John no adjustment needed to go to
Tommy John's comm slash up here you get
20% off your first order that's Tommy
John comm slash up hero for 20% off
Tommy John comm slash Shapiro and that
gets you your 20% off your first order
plus it lets them know that we sent you
you're not gonna regret it the underwear
are just terrific and so are their other
clothing items ok again this Tommy John
comm slash up here oh no adjustment
needed and that is meant in every sense
of the phrase ok so the media lost their
minds yesterday because they didn't just
say what Trump is saying here is that
he's judging immigrants by their country
of origin and that's bigoted there you'd
have a pretty solid argument right you'd
have a solid argument now as I say Trump
could say listen I wasn't saying that
you're judging people by their country
of origin I'm saying that if you are
going to judge people by their country
of origin as the university visa lottery
suggests then you do have to look at the
difference between the cultures of Great
Britain and the cultures of say Russia
or Spain or Greece or any other country
right you're gonna have a hierarchy of
countries from which it is most likely
that people are going to be easily able
to assimilate that doesn't seem
completely unreasonable to me and Trump
could even say if you look at that
Washington Post story I say as much when
I said I want more Asian immigrants
meaning from places like South Korea
which has a very westernized country as
opposed to say as opposed say Ivory
Coast right there there are certain
countries where integration is going to
be easier then you would have to provide
some statistics to prove it I will talk
about the statistics in a little while
but that is not what the media are going
nuts over so the media have gone nuts
over a few different things here the
first thing they've gone nuts over is
the actual vulgarity that Trump said the
word bleep hole now number one Trump
said the word bleep hole behind closed
doors and I find it a little bit
ridiculous that everybody in the media
is saying how dare Trump say that there
are countries that are bleep holes
I've sat with a lot of these members of
the media they will call red states
bleep holes they will call their
apartment a bleep hole
they will suggest that there is it that
the recycling center two blocks from
their house is a bleep hole the idea
that you can't say the word bleep hole
that suddenly they're very offended by
this is belied by the fact that they
then went on
TV and decided to say the actual word
bleep hole but not bleeping it over and
over and over so Jim Acosta went nuts
yesterday and he just decided to say
bleep hole 1,000 times in a row again I
don't know what editorial standard is
here I know NPR has now said that
they're not gonna bleep it out they're
gonna say Shh hole right there and
they're not actually gonna believe it
out they're gonna say the entire word
now what's amazing about this is of
course this is not the first time in
American politics that people have
cursed before before I get to the media
going crazy over this first I want to
show you okay you remember when Joe
Biden it was a big headline Joe Biden
said to Barack Obama then when Obamacare
passes out on an open mic this is a big
effing deal flashback okay here's a
Biden saying that ladies and gentlemen
the president the United States of
America Barack Obama
thank you everybody okay so he says
there if you get in here it is a big
effing deal right there's a big effing
deal and this was such not a big deal to
people that the Democratic Party put out
a t-shirt with this on it or they put
out a t-shirt with the with health
reform is a BFT I remember they sold
this on the Democratic Party website did
the media actually write out f you know
actually spell it out did they actually
spell out the F word did they actually
report that that's what he said or do
they bleep it out of course they bleeped
it out right they bleeped it out the
same way that weren't bleeping it out
same thing is true when LA mayor Eric
Garcetti swore to King's rally this is
just a couple of years ago right this
guy wants to run for president and he
got up and he said you know this is a
this is a big effing day and is what it
look like but there are two rules in
politics they say never ever be pictured
with a drink in your hand and never
swear but this is a big guys okay so
there he is saying big effing day did
the media print any of that of course
they didn't print any of that but now
they're going to say over and
over and over because Trump is the
president mean let's be clear this is
why they are changing their editorial
standard so here's Jim Acosta saying it
over and over and over
we bleeped it out but he did not believe
it which the president referred to
countries like Haiti and countries in
Africa as a whole
obviously I apologize for using this
word here but this is a quote from the
president why are we having all these
people from all countries come here why
are we having all these people from you
get the point and I noticed you well if
you hesitated to use that word I
hesitate to use it myself as an S whole
or all is what the word that the
Washington Post is quoting the president
is saying okay I remember when they were
suggesting there was a rumor that I
think was Barack Obama directly to
Jeffrey Goldberg so you heard about
Benjamin Netanyahu if I'm not mistaken I
think that that that happened as well
this new editorial standard where you
only quote the curse word in order to
humiliate Trump is obviously directed at
Trump Chris Cuomo who's just an ass of
epic order he came out and he said that
Trump gave this war this word to the
world right the no one never heard this
word before Trump actually originated it
the president is just showing you who he
is this is who he is okay we sum it up
in a word
okay here it is this is the gift that he
decided to give the American he says the
president this is who he is he is a
bleep all right this is what Chris Cuomo
now says about Trump so are they really
that upset about the vulgarity of course
they're not upset about the vulgarity
that's nonsense
okay that's nonsense they don't care
about them all Garrity now the second
thing they become upset about again
wildly overshooting the mark if they
want to hit Trump they should hit him on
the idea that immigrants cannot be
judged by their country of origin right
that's where they should live they
should live right there but they're too
stupid they can't do it it's impossible
for them so instead the media have
decided to say that there are no
countries that are bleep holes all
countries are fantastic right there are
none all the countries are great if you
believe this ask an expatriate from
North Korea whether the country is a
bleep hole ask an expatriate from Sudan
whether they would prefer to go back I
mean only the left could be the stupid
seriously you have to be a to fall
into this particular trap saying that
there's no such thing as a bleep hole
country my rich Lowry humiliated rich
Lowry of NASCAR will be humiliated Joan
Walsh a CNN contributor yesterday on the
network specifically asking her like
you're saying that that some countries
are not bleep holes would you rather
live in Haiti with its with its average
income GDP its average annual GDP per
capita at seven hundred and thirty
dollars a year its average life
expectancy at 63 it's it's literacy rate
at sixty one percent would rather live
there or Norway where the average income
is sixty two thousand dollars a year and
watch Joan Walsh try to run screaming
from this question with her hair on fire
you're really contradicting what the
administration has already said they
have said the reason that they're ending
these protections for Haitians and for
Salvadorans specifically is that those
countries are no longer basket cases and
they can go back now so you can't really
so if you say they shouldn't go back
because they're so dangerous or so
violently left position you're saying
they're and a lot of these people have
lived here ten twelve seventeen years
they they haven't caused trouble I don't
know I don't know like come on I don't
know of course she knows are you kidding
Joanne walls probably wants to move to
Norway now okay that's that's
surd it's absurd and she's not the only
one doing this little worst of course of
Stephen Colbert so Stephen Colbert last
night goes on his show and and this is
clip 17 and he explains that there are
no bleep whole countries except the
United States were the only one because
Trump is president this afternoon he was
meeting with lawmakers to discuss
immigration policy several of these
lawmakers suggested lifting restrictions
for immigrants from Haiti El Salvador
and various African countries Trump
reportedly said where are we having all
these people from whole countries come
here sir they're not whole countries for
one Donald Trump isn't their president
okay stop it right there
the idea that this is gonna win
Democrats elections are they insane this
is gonna be their pitch that Haiti is
not a bleep hole
but the United States so bleep all cuz
Trump is president like what I don't
know that this logic escapes me again
there's plenty of ways to hit Trump over
these comments and plenty of reason to
do so but to live in the nobody's a
bleep whole country except for the
United States I mean try you yeah good
luck with that one
good luck with that one also there is
something a little bit contradictory
about the idea that people have to
escape bad countries to come here but we
won't label the country bad in the first
place right so Anderson Cooper yesterday
talks about how he's been to Haiti and
he's helping Haitian children this this
is well it's a great story but I'm
wondering you know if Anderson Cooper is
making the case that people from Haiti
are wonderful that's fine but if he's
making the case that Haiti is not a
bleep hole country you know in the sort
of common parlance that it's not a
crappy place to live I mean obviously it
is a crappy place to live in Anderson
Cooper's telling you a story about how
crappy a place it is to live there he is
I was there when a young girl named B
who'd been trapped in rubble for nearly
a day was rescued by people who had no
heavy equipment they just had their
god-given strength and their
determination and their courage I was
there when a five year old boy named Mon
Lee was rescued after being buried for
more than seven days do you know what
strength it takes to survive on
rainwater buried under concrete a
five-year-old boy buried for seven days
he shouldn't slap your hand hard when
they shake it they look you in the eye
they don't blink they stand tall
and they have dignity it's a dignity
many in this white house could learn
from it's okay so I totally agree with
everything that he's saying about
Haitians I know a lot of Haitians who
are just wonderful wonderful people
people who immigrated to this country by
and large our wonderful people who are
coming to make the country better but if
your argument is that Haiti is a great
country
Haiti is not a great place to live okay
you just talked about a kid who was
buried for seven days under rubble it
doesn't happen in the United States we
don't get that in the United States on a
regular basis we're not tens of
thousands of people who are buried under
rubble and when an earthquake happens
because America is a better place to
live then Haiti America is a better
country than Haiti okay and I mean that
by government it's a better governed
country and I mean that in terms of
whatever whatever cultural attributes
lead to a bad governance there that's
not to suggest people can't come from
Haiti and be wonderful American citizens
they can't but to suggest there no
differences between countries is just
silly it's just so away and that's why
I'm so bewildered by the attack that the
media have chosen to take care now in a
second I'm gonna explain where the media
are on more solid ground and how they
are universal in their consummation and
where there's a possible read that is a
little more vague than the one that they
are espousing in just a second first I
want to say thank you to our sponsors
over at legacy box so you're looking to
preserve your memories right you're
looking to preserve all of those old
family memories you've got all these old
family videos you've never looked at
them in 30 years they're just sitting
out there in your garage gathering mold
it's time for you to grab all that stuff
and send it to my friends over at legacy
box right you grab all that stuff you
send it over to legacy box and what they
do is they convert all of it to a DVD or
a thumb drive ready to watch and share
and relive we've done some of this with
with the Shapiro materials it makes for
a fantastic gift particularly Father's
Day or Mother's Day great makes a great
Valentine's Day gift again you're
preserving all those old memories and
instead of you having to schlep around
tons of boxes instead now you get to
bring a DVD or a thumb drive if there's
god forbid some sort of natural disaster
a fire in your house there's some reason
you have to leave your house you're
moving it makes it a lot easier to grab
a thumb drive than to than to put a
bunch of photo albums in your car that's
what it's for 2018 is the year you
preserve your family's legacy that's
what legacy box is and for a limited
time right now you save 40% at legacy
box comm slash Ben get started for just
45 bucks right now at legacy box comm
slash Ben
legacy box comm slash Ben when you use
the slash pen you save 40 percent this
is just a fantastic
fantastic service I have long suggested
that people need to preserve their
memories because once those memories are
gone there's no one there to relive them
with you you need to go out and preserve
your memories today that's what legacy
box is for legacy box combat / been
again that's legacy box comm so I spend
say 40 percent and get started for 45
bucks ok so now we get to the root of
the matter people who are suggesting
that Trump is a racist so the list of
people in media who are saying that
Trump is racist for saying this are it's
at endless right it's it's a very very
long list so here's just a quick montage
of everybody in the media suggesting
that President Trump is obviously a
racist for for the stuff that he said
the President of the United States is
racist it confirms what we've I've said
on this show before Donald Trump is a
bigot he speaks in a racist way it just
shows that you know the president has
racist views let's be real clear this is
the most racist bigoted al Sharpton my
comments that we've heard a president
may but it doesn't make what he said any
less ignorant or any less racist not
racial not racially charged racist let's
not kid ourselves miss remar by the
President of the United States smacks of
blatant racism the most odious and
insidious racism masquerading poorly as
immigration policy this is ignorant this
is ignorance to speak in such vile
racist terms we can dance around it and
not really put our finger on it but the
president seems to harbor racist
feelings about people of color okay now
last one is Jim Acosta of course Jim
Acosta is is the White House press
correspondent he's not an opinion guy
right he's supposed to be the objective
news journalist so there are a few
things here so as I have suggested it is
a plausible read that the President of
the United States is saying the people
from Haiti cannot properly immigrate to
the United States because they are bad
people because a bad country that would
be racist okay that would be racist it
would be stupid to say that it's that he
harbors you know feelings of animosity
for people of color as a whole I think
would be a little bit too broad
considering that in the same article it
says that he wants more people to come
in from countries like South Korea
that's full of Asian people who are not
white but
that said yes this is a not gonna
pretend it's not a plausible read it is
a plausible read you know Mia love who's
the daughter I believe of Haitian
immigrants she tweeted out her statement
on this she said the president comments
our unkind divisive elitist and fly in
the face of our nation's values this
behavior is unacceptable from the leader
of our nation my parents came from one
of those countries but proudly took an
oath of allegiance to the United States
and took on the responsibilities of
everything that being a citizen comes
with they never took a thing from our
federal government it worked hard paid
taxes and rose from nothing to take care
of and provide opportunities for their
children they taught their children to
do the same that's the American dream
the President must apologize both to the
American people and to the nation's he
so wants and leave maligned okay so you
know I think that this is a a perfect
statement I honestly I think what Mia
love says here is essentially correct
you come here you work hard you play by
the rules you assimilate you get
involved in the American dream Aaron
anyone who does that should be able to
come in and if what Trump is saying is
that people should not be able to come
in based on their country of origin
that's silly
okay that's silly it's not just silly
it's racist it actually is racist and it
is bigoted but there's another plausible
way to read what Trump is saying right
the other plausible way to weed read
what Trump is saying is for him to be
saying what I said earlier which is that
if you are going to judge people alone
by their country which you should not
you should not but that's what the
diversity visa lottery program does if
you're gonna judge people's merit based
on just country of origin you cannot
pretend that all countries of origin are
equally likely to produce the same level
of a similar of assimilate able citizens
that would just be silly
it's obviously untrue and the data
support this right there's a study from
the the Institute for the Study of labor
December 2009 Ruth's wife oh oh you
Larry of Georgia Institute of Technology
and Mahalo awawa the University of
Vermont and here are their findings okay
their findings are although immigrants
from South America Canada Oceania and
Europe use any form of welfare at the
same rate as us born immigrants from
Asia Africa Central America and us
protectorates they those ones use wealth
or more so if you're an immigrant from
Asia Africa Central America or US
protectorates you use welfare more and
then they actually analyze to see
whether this was just based on the level
of poverty that people are when they
come over to the United States if it's
based on family size they say we reject
the hypothesis that welfare usages I
done
across immigrants in us-born and also
reject the related hypothesis that
welfare usage is identical for immigrant
groups this results suggest that welfare
usage is not affected by solely economic
and standard demographics this implies
that culture value network information
or institution of groups might have a
significant role to play in an
individual's choice to use welfare
culture values Network information and
institutional background were not
controlled for in our probability model
and may explain the differential welfare
usage across group despite controlling
for the standard economic and
demographic variables that should
predict welfare usage birthplace matters
for wealth or usage in the u.s. this is
their conclusion birthplace matters from
welfare usage in the u.s. now that's not
again to imply that where you were born
means that inevitably you're going to
use welfare that's silly and racist it
doesn't mean that as individuals we can
judge you based on your country of
origin it does mean that if you are
going to say we get to now take in
10,000 immigrants those 10,000
immigrants are either going to come from
South Korea or they're going to come
from Russia right in Asian country or
they're going to come from with with a
history of Western civilization or
Russia where there is very little
history of westernization right which
one are you going to choose and you can
only choose one you're going to just
going to do it based on the country
description then you would probably say
I'd want the South Korean citizens and
not necessarily the Russian citizens if
you were going to create a hierarchy of
people who are able to assimilate easily
in the United States it's not a rip on
individual Russians hey my ancestors are
from Russia my parent my
great-grandparents came over from
Lithuania right the idea that that that
it doesn't matter at all where you came
from in terms of the average if you're
doing it simply by numbers is obviously
not true
but the idea that you can judge
individuals based on this is racist
right this is the same thing as saying
and the black crime rate in the United
States is higher than the white crime
rate in the United States this is true
but it is racist to say that a black
person this black individual right here
is going to commit crime because he is
black right that's not the same thing
and that distinction is important you
can say that that on average people who
come from sub-saharan African countries
are gonna have a tougher time
integrating and assimilating into the
United States than people coming from
Great Britain but that's not racist but
it is racist to say this particular
person from Sudan cannot
simile because they're from Sudan that's
racist okay so that distinction makes a
difference and I don't know that Trump
knows enough to actually make that
distinction I don't know if he does
maybe he doesn't I mean the implicate
yeah as I've said before you know his
history shows that he said stuff like a
Mexican judge meaning a judge who's
descended from Mexican parents I can't
properly judge his case because they're
Mexican like there are cases where Trump
has sounded really bad and racist and if
you read these comments in the context
of those comments it's hard to avoid the
conclusion the media won't you drop but
I would like more evidence on what
actually happened in this conversation
because all I'm hearing a secondhand I
don't have a full transcript in front of
me and I am I am shy of jumping on the
media's accounts of a secondhand
conversation that was being related by
Democrats I think that to do that would
be unfair I hope that I would hold the
same standard for for the Obama
administration or for any other
politician for that matter so yeah again
it should Trump have said this no should
he clarify what he meant absolutely
should he should he walk it back as much
as he can he absolutely should but the
left suggestion that there's no such
thing as a bleep whole country is silly
the left suggestion that they're angry
because he cursed is silly and the left
suggestion that the only way to read
that comment is simply in terms of
Donald Trump is saying that every
immigrant from Haiti is bad because
they're black I think that that requires
a logical jump at least maybe that jump
is real maybe that's what Trump is
thinking but there's a lot of
mind-reading going on and I think that
that mind-reading is not necessarily is
not necessarily guaranteed to be correct
okay so in just a second we're gonna
give you the latest on the jacket deal
plus things I like things I hate and the
mailbag first you're gonna have to go
over to Daley wire calm and subscribe
when you do then you not only get to be
part of the mailbag which is right now
you get to ask questions specific
questions you also get to see the rest
of the show live you can see the rest of
Cleveland still alive and and Knowles's
show live and get to be part of the
conversation which is happening with
Andrew Clavin on Tuesday the 16th 5:00
p.m. Eastern 2 p.m. Pacific ask drew
questions live in the daily wired
chatroom when you become a subscriber to
daily wire $9.99 a month $99 a year he
gets the you the annual subscription
including this the very greatest in
beverage vessels the leftist ears hot or
cold mug which is just overflowing these
days for a variety of reasons both good
and bad I check it out you get that
with the annual subscription if you just
want to listen later SoundCloud iTunes
YouTube Google Play stitcher we're
available on all of those outlets we are
the largest fastest growing conservative
podcast in the nation
[Music]
now one of the things that's gonna be
fascinating about what Trump just said
is how it impacts his base because what
happened yesterday is that the
Republicans basically signal that they
were going to cave on data so the
deferred action for childhood arrivals
program of course is the program that
Obama instituted to basically give green
cards in the long run
to dreamers so-called dreamers people
who are brought over as as young people
through no fault of their own as the
phrase goes and have been in the country
for years so Trump wanted an end to
chain migration he wanted an end to the
diversity visa lottery program and he
wanted his wall and maybe even Phi
that's what he wanted here's the deal
they're talking about cutting right now
by the way this deal is not gonna happen
now I think now that - I made these
comments the chance of a dad could be
went down to zero Democrats know they
can posture as much as they possibly
could want it's why Trump should shut
his mouth it's a huge mistake
politically and also morally for him to
do it he did the fact that and that
Trump said this sunk even the
possibility was deal now the Democrats
are gonna wait around they're gonna let
daca die on Trump's watch claim Trump is
a racist and then know that Trump will
just reinstate daca himself which will
probably be what happens come March in
any case before all this blew up Trump
was talking yesterday about this deal
you ready for this cuz it ain't good
path to citizenship for daca recipients
and those eligible for daca who did not
sign up only only 2.8 billion dollars
for border security some 1.6 billion for
fence barrier they're saying it will
cost a minimum of 18 billion dollars to
actually build a fence an additional 1.2
billion for other border priorities
again not enough money family based
migration parents of daca cannot become
citizens but will get temporary
protected status so that doesn't really
change much because that just means that
when a Democrat enters office we'll give
them citizenship and then Visa Lottery
some of the 50,000 slots will be used
for people in the country who have lost
their temporary protected status and
some will be used for low immigration
countries so I'll just reallocate some
of the diversity visa lottery stuff very
very weak deal if this is all
Republicans can get out of this Jeff
Flake who is you know pretty weak on
immigration he came for and said we're
very close on the deal this was his
statement yesterday the bipartisan group
I'm talking about the six of us working
that we're shopping among our colleagues
now we don't want to release details
until we talk to more of our colleagues
well there's so much for that that's
pretty much done right now that's pretty
much dead so I think that it is in
just another it's just another side
effect of the fact that the the
President of the United States cannot
keep his mouth shut and he'd be better
off just being quiet in in many
scenarios okay time for a couple of
things I like them some things that I
hate so things that I like today I
wanted to point out that immigrants from
low quality countries right immigrants
from if you want to say bleep whole
countries I think Nazi Germany would
rank as a bleep hole government
immigrants who are trying to escape that
have provided some of the great
contributions to Americans say forget
about the atomic bomb which is which is
an atomic energy which is obviously a
contribution of people who fled Nazi
Germany but some of our great movie
music so Eric corn gold was a Jewish
émigrés from Nazi Germany he left in the
late twenties I believe he came here and
he wrote some of the great American
scores great classical composer really
underappreciated because film scores
aren't underappreciated if you don't
know the original Adventures of Robin
Hood I think it may have been the very
first movie I recommended on things I
liked in on this show then the music is
just glorious it was conducted by a Eric
Korngold here's a little bit of that
music
[Music]
so I mean that's great music it's not
just that okay the the the Max Steiner
was another emigrant from Nazi Germany
he wrote probably most famous score in
Hollywood history of course the the
music - gone with the wind
[Music]
these just glorious stuff so the idea
that you come from a crappy country
therefore you can't contribute to the
United States is just asinine and racist
and stupid and bigoted if that's what
Trump was saying then he's all of those
things that's not what Trump was saying
then he is not and I would urge people
to actually look at the evidence in
front of them and come to your own
conclusion I think that either read to
be frank with you is plausible but I
don't think that it is I don't think
that it is necessarily a irrevocable
proof that Trump is racist that that you
read it in one of these two ways okay so
time for you know let's get the things I
hate and I'll just go straight to the
mailbag so let's do some mailbag here we
go
June L writes hey Ben what exactly is
the problem with Keynesian economics so
the problem with Keynesian economics is
the suggestion that if you redistribute
money from top to bottom or you
jumpstart the economy by borrowing
against the future and injecting cash
into into the spending matrix that this
somehow betters the economy in any real
way it will increase consumption of
course but the question is whether
consumption alone drives economic growth
and the answer is what actually drives
economic growth what actually makes your
life better economic growth is it
doesn't is not a phrase that means a
whole hell of a lot makes your life
better is a phrase that means a whole
hell of a lot it may make your life
better in the temporary here and now for
the government to give you a little bit
more money it will make your life a lot
better now and in the future for people
who know what to do with their money to
keep their own money and invest it in
things that are going to benefit you in
other words money in Bill Gates's pocket
is actually more useful than money in my
pocket and I'm talking about me
personally right I'm pretty good with my
money Bill Gates has made better use of
his money than I have made of my money
not only has he invested it wisely he's
also built a company with tens of
thousands of employees and built
products that millions of people use and
the idea that when you take money from
borrowing against the future when you
take money and inject it into the
economy that this somehow gets the gears
running again that demand is what
creates supply is not true supply
creates demand meaning the reason that
you buy a new product is not because you
have a little bit of extra money in your
pocket it's because the new product is
available you couldn't buy and I put you
couldn't buy an iPhone 30 years ago
because the iPhone didn't exist it
wouldn't matter how much money the
government gave you you can buy an
iPhone now because there were creators
who discovered the hidden
and in the marketplace and crafted a
product specifically for it this is my
problem with Keynesian economics the
idea of the multiplier effect I think is
is sheer nonsense Henry Hazlitt has a
very long but thorough look at the flaws
in Keynesian theory it's it's called the
the new economics I think the flaws in
the new economics something like that is
about a 500 page book but he really
blows up our Keynesianism with alacrity
Niels has been how do you feel about the
US taxing its citizens abroad as the
only country in the world to do this do
you feel this is right or wrong do you
first see this being revoked in the
future I think that it's idiotic to tax
your citizens abroad if you're abroad
and you're earning all your money abroad
I'm not sure what the United States has
to say about that per se I but I feel
that generally about taxes here I mean I
think that the only possible argument
can be made is taxing our citizens
abroad for defense purposes because our
military defense you'll brought the same
as it would at home right maybe that's
the only excuse outs has been what do
you think of Switzerland's recent
legislation that took away welfare
recipients right to vote well I don't
know enough about this so I actually
want to check the facts on it before I
comment so I'll beg off that question
and so I can actually get some more
information
Ari says hey Ben you speak a lot about
the West's hierarchy of victimhood which
groups are more likely to be victimized
to get a place a higher place in the
hierarchy based on this why are Jews
lower on the hierarchy than Muslims and
Latinos when according to the FBI
statistics Jews face more hate crimes by
a large percentage well the reason is
because the left does not perceive
victimhood in terms of being victims of
hate crime the left or victims of crime
generally the left perceives victimhood
in people they perceive to be harmed by
the system really in terms of economics
right this is why the the intersectional
hierarchy is basically a Marxist
invention the idea is that Latinos and
Muslims are more put upon by American
society because they are on average poor
Jews are highly educated and rich in the
United States that means they cannot be
victims even if they are many times over
more victimized than than other victims
so-called victim groups in the United
States Jackson's been what's your status
regarding your parents on the daily show
well I got back to Trevor Noah on the
daily show and I said if you want to do
this thing live as in live live then I'm
happy to do it if you want to do it on
tape delay I'm not gonna do that because
I saw how you sliced and diced Jonah
Goldberg and I'm not going to allow you
to slice me out of context and then not
give me a copy of the tape so three
million people see me you know getting
destroyed by Trevor Noah when in reality
it's the other way around I don't think
we've or
back from them ever since I made that
demand which is not particularly
shocking
let's see Nikolas says dear Benin was it
your response to the 1929 Great
Depression would be from a policy
standpoint would you just simply cut
taxes launched public works etc I
wouldn't have launched public works I
probably would have cut taxes I would
not have gotten the government deeply
involved to be frank I mean there was it
there was a huge economic meltdown in
1920-21 and the entire market recovered
quickly the reason that you had an
eight-year lengthening of the Great
Depression according to UCLA economist
is because of all the government
intervention ISM I certainly would not
have raised tariffs I certainly would
not have moved toward government
intervention ISM in the fiscal sector
there there are two theories basically
in conservative circles from why the
Great Depression happened in the first
place one theory is the so called
tightening of the money theory which is
the Milton Friedman Chicago School of
Economics and they suggest that the Fed
policy was too stingy and therefore we
needed to inject more money into the
economy with a low inflation rate which
would have allowed people to retain
their mortgages for example I tend not
to agree with Milton Friedman I'm more
on the Vienna School of Economics on
this thing which suggests almost the
opposite the they almost argue the
opposite they sort of argue that the the
Fed policy was too inflationary and the
stock market was overvalued and that's
why he saw a stock market crash and that
the only way to get out of it would have
been to mmm if not tighten the grip on
money then to then to maintain the gold
standard now the gold standard was
technically maintained but gold was
revalued against the dollar under FDR in
a pretty routine basis Josh says Haman
with censorship against conservatives
discovered on so-called free speech
platforms like Google and Twitter do you
think we'll see a rise of US
conservative social media platform I
don't think that there will be a choice
if this continues and I know that there
are institutional investors who are
looking to do just that Spencer says hey
Ben you mentioned that Shakespeare is
one of your favorite authors which a
plays of his are your favorites are
there any place that strikers containing
particular relevance to the current
political atmosphere in the United
States well the the the best ones from
Shakespeare I love his tragedies I'm not
as big a fan of Shakespeare's comedies I
enjoy them but his tragedies are of
course his great masterpieces and those
would be in in order of my preference I
probably go handle it over Lear but it's
really tight so maybe Hamlet Lear
Macbeth and then I thought well those
are considered his four
our greatest works and I agree with that
and then I love his historical place - I
really like Henry the fifth Julius
Caesar is fantastic the thing about
Shakespeare is virtually everything that
he writes is relevant because so much of
it is political it's so much of it is
political there I mean I made a lot of
Lea references during the last election
cycle with regard to you know how Trump
treated members of the media who did his
dirty work for him you know people being
sycophants in front of him I have made
references to Hillary Clinton being a
corrupt figure in search of power you
know a sort of macbeth figure and when
it comes to politics julius caesar has a
lot of reference to the the politics of
our age how populism can be whipped up
by mob and then somebody can jump in
front of it and use it for its own
particular purposes even if it's started
off well right even if it's Brutus
trying to start a popular uprising
against tyranny
somebody can jump in front of that and
then you misuse the movement right
that's that's very possible as well you
see with Bernie Sanders I think it's a
certain extent you saw with Trump so
there's so many great Shakespeare plays
that have contemporary relevance Isaac
says hey Ben what are your thoughts I'm
going back to a gold standard and how
would it impact the economy so as I've
said going back to a gold standard I
think would be useful the way that you
would do that is pegging the value of
the dollar to the value of gold the
reason I say that is because the value
of the gold doesn't change radically
over time in terms of the amount of gold
that's being discovered so it used to be
that the value of gold changed a lot
because there's so much new gold being
discovered but they're really in that
much gold on planet earth and it's not
like tons of it is being discovered on a
daily basis so you don't have to worry
about the fluctuations as you do right
now and for example Bitcoin the beauty
of going back to a gold standard is that
the government then does not have the
capacity to inflate itself out of bad
spending habits right the reason that
you can inflate yourself out of bad
spending habits there or spend a lot of
money is because the government can then
come in and just inflate its way right
out of it and that's something that I
think is deeply detrimental to the
economy Dayne says hey Ben who's your
favorite director currently in Hollywood
what are your top three movies made in
the last 10 years
okay so favorite director currently in
Hollywood if I've not made this clear as
Christopher Nolan Christopher Nolan
followed by Christopher Nolan he's the
best director working in Hollywood and
top three movies made in the last ten
years so I believe lives of others is
just outside the realm what year was
lives of others I think that lives of
others was 2003 2006 so I just messed
with lives of others the The Dark Knight
was 2007
was 2007 or 2008 well count that is the
last 10 years and so in 2008 whiplash I
loved it I think what lashes a fantastic
film and then I'm trying to think of
what my third film would be I like as I
say I love no one so I really do like a
lot of movies that other people don't
like of his I really like interstellar
people really like Dunkirk I like
interstellar I think I think internal
actually has a little more heart than
Dunkirk they you know I'll have to go
back and look at my list of the of the
movies that I've liked over the past
over the past few years but that those
are the ones that pop to mind
immediately okay Matthew says hey Ben
quick abortion question what would you
say to a libertarian from a legal
standpoint thinks abortion should be
legal given that there is no
constitutional obligation to protect non
citizens but from a moral standpoint
thinks abortion is repugnant well there
is a constitutional obligation to
protect non-citizens in the United
States from being killed right like you
you're not allowed to kill non citizens
if there's an immigrant in the United
States illegally I can't just drive down
some local Home Depot and bash a guy
with a rock that's not a thing so that
that argument doesn't cut a lot of
weight with me Meghan says the city I
live in has a huge problem with an
increasing homeless population how
should my city council handle this issue
well the truth is that being homeless
should be illegal it is illegal it is
loitering the reason that the homeless
population is so high is because local
and state have really underfunded mental
health services this one is on local
government local and state need to fund
mental health services and then when
people are on the streets and are
suffering from severe mental disorders
you know they have schizophrenia and
they can't take care of themselves it is
evil to leave them out on the streets
not taking their medication it is evil
to suggest that it is an aspect of
freedom to not take your medication and
live in a delusional paranoid world is
insane it's bad for citizens it's bad
for the homeless people it's really bad
the vast majority of people who are
homeless from the studies that I have
seen have some sort of mental disability
are alcoholic or are drug users you do
not have the privilege of living on the
streets my tax is paid for those streets
I have as much access to those streets
as you do and if you are occupying them
then you are loitering or you're
violating the law it's not that hard to
clean up the homeless problem but you
have to have some sympathy for people
who are mentally ill and people who are
drug users so I think that it's not a
matter of just providing housing for the
homeless a lot of people don't want to
abide by the rules
the rules are for everyone and you don't
get to avoid them just because you wish
to live on the streets users's - I'm a
Muslim Canadian listener and fan of your
work
why are Muslims on the web dunno in the
West on the left side of the political
spectrum when we hold similar
conservative values to Christians and
Jews such as our views on abortion and
traditional marriage whereas the left is
anti religion in my view Muslim Jews and
Christians are natural political allies
in the West how can i as a law student
guide the Muslim community away from the
left and toward the Conservatives where
I believe we belong well I think a lot
of this changed after 9/11 if you look
at the 2000 election i believe that
george w bush actually won a plurality
of muslims in the united states in the
2000 election after 9/11 things
radically shifted because foreign policy
became the dividing line for a lot of
Muslims in the West who saw Israel or or
or American policy in Iraq or
Afghanistan or profiling of Muslims as
the chief political issue in terms of
social issues muslims jews and
christians are basically on the same
page in terms of economic issues i think
that there's a fair argument to be made
by a lot of reformed and moderate
muslims that conservative economics is
on the same page as well personal
responsibility messages that you
actually have responsibility to people
so i agree with you but i think foreign
policy if you're moderate in the muslim
community and you don't actually suffer
from a lot of the delusions that i think
some of the more radical members of the
Muslim community suffer from less so in
the West but more in other countries
then I think you're more likely to be on
the conservative side of the aisle and
all the other issues and maybe you vote
Republican John says hey Ben you often
recommend non-fiction books and
fictional TV do you ever read fiction
and if so what books would you recommend
I recommend a lot of fiction books on
the show I think my favorite is Moby
Dick so that is where I would start
um I'm also a big fan of Leon URIs is a
writer he's kind of a fun writer if you
just want fun writing one of my favorite
books that nobody's ever heard of his
book called the secret of Santa vitória
by Robert Crichton so see if you can
pick that one up on Amazon
I love reading fiction I think I just
recommended a few weeks ago a bunch of
books a bunch of fiction books by what's
the name of the author who did Howard
the dog there's there's a bunch of and
cartel the cartel don don Don Winslow's
I just recommended some fiction books by
him two weeks ago maybe so then go back
and look at my entire things I like
lists I believe there are people online
who actually keep tabs on all of these
things so we should at some point we
probably will haha but but check that
out
Trevor says hi Ben I got your mother
from my fiancee up here in British
Columbia Canada we're both huge fans our
question is once you have an ideal
small-government how do you prevent it
from inevitably getting larger over time
well the answer there is that education
education and education is the only
solution the founders thought they had
cured this problem obviously not
parchment barriers are just parchment
you require an educated population in
order to maintain freedom is wide Ronald
Reagan said that freedom is always one
generation away from extinction that's
why I'm optimistic that in an era in
which freedom seems to be less and less
respected I always think freedom is one
generation away from revival Justin says
haman my friends are very anti-israel a
common argument they make is this why
did you get to rule their ancestral
homeland after centuries of foreign
occupation but Native American tribes
don't how to respond to this they aren't
religious so any biblical arguments I
try to make usually fall flat well I
mean the truth is that Native American
tribes do have reservations I think that
it's unjust how the reservations are
created I think that American policy
toward Native Americans has been
historically quite awful but the idea
that there is not Native American role
in these areas is not true I mean
federally speaking these are these are
territories that are independent of
state government right a Native American
reservations are governed by federal law
so there actually is self-governance in
Native American reservations the
question is what sort of culture do you
think ought to have self-rule so the
idea of a Jewish democracy I think that
should have self-rule because I think
Judaism has values Judaic values have
values and democracy has value and I
don't think these things are in conflict
as far as Native American a self rule I
think it would depend on the values that
are being promulgated by various Native
American communities I don't think all
of the values are necessarily the same
and then you know kind of linking
together all Native American tribes
under one broad rubric I don't want to
pretend knowledge where I don't have so
I'm not going so you know my general
rule is if you can govern a country well
or a territory well and if you have a
historic claim to that area then we can
talk about it but when it comes to
Native American tribes there are some
serious questions as to whether there's
historic Native American claims
particularly and considering that there
is no such concept in many cultures in
Native American culture originally of
private property or tribal ownership of
particular property so in other words
now we're now we're sort of past that
point but
the idea of having sovereign Native
American land is basically written into
American law I mean this become a major
issue with regard to Child Protective
Services and the and the Indian the
Department of Indian Affairs the
Department of Native American affairs
already so we have reached the end of
this week's mail back we'll be back here
on Monday I'm sure I'm sure that things
will continue to burn down because they
always do and we'll be here to help you
sift through the ashes I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Plummer executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is austin stevens
edited by alex and Garo audio is mixed
by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is by
Jesuit Oliveira the Ben Shapiro show is
a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright for publishing 2018